quelles orientations budgétaires pour
2018 le conseil départemental du
haut-rhin prépare son prochain plan de
financement au programme continue à
faire des économies sur les charges
générales de fonctionnement du
département maîtriser l'endettement
actuel à hauteur de 370 millions d'euros
75 millions d'euros devraient ainsi être
investis en 2018 soit 2,7 millions de
plus qu'en 2010 est le conseil
départemental du haut-rhin souhaite
faire de l'emploi et de la jeunesse une
priorité pour 2018
tout en poursuivant son action au
service de la protection de l'enfance à
partir de 2018
le conseil départemental deviendra un
véritable acteur qui rapprochera les
personnes en recherche d'emploi et les
employeurs et nous pensons par l'
arrivée aussi à réduire le nombre de
bénéficiaires du rsa
pour ce qui est de la réussite éducative
des collégiens il y à l'investissement
et puis il y à des actions volontaristes
du département pour ce qui est de
l'investissement
nous venons de faire une grande
réflexion
le livre blanc des collèges qui nous
permet aujourd'hui de lancer un grand
plan d'investissement dans les collèges
de 150 millions d'euros pour ce qui est
des bâtiments et de 10 millions d'euros
pour ce qui est de l'investissement du
numérique donc 160 millions d'euros sur
dix ans
[Musique]